Nos preguntan: "¿Cuál de las siguientes soluciones
contiene la mayor cantidad de moles de iones CI?"
Pausa el video y trata de resolverlo. Muy bien,
veamos cómo podemos pensar en esto. La relación
entre molaridad, litros y moles es la molaridad
de algún soluto se define como el número de moles
de ese soluto dividido entre los litros de
solución. U otra forma de pensarlo es que si
queremos calcular el número de moles de soluto
multiplicamos ambos lados por litros, así que
tenemos litros de solución. Lo voy a escribir de
esta manera para abreviar: por moles por litro,
o podemos decir: la molaridad del soluto, y eso
va a ser igual al número de moles del soluto. Y
si vemos cada una de estas opciones, nos están
dando un volumen, nos están dando el volumen en
mililitros, que podríamos convertir en litros
de una manera directa, y luego nos están dando
la molaridad. Así que esencialmente sólo debemos
asegurarnos de que estamos tratando con litros,
y luego multiplicarlos y obtendremos el
número de moles de este soluto, o este soluto,
de este soluto y luego de este soluto. Pero
tenemos que tener cuidado porque nos dicen "la
mayor cantidad de moles de iones CI". Y para las
opciones A y B cada mol de la molécula a la que
nos referimos tendría 1 mol de iones cloruro; pero
en las opciones C y D cada mol, por ejemplo, del
cloruro de magnesio, en realidad tiene 2 moles de
cloruro; lo mismo ocurre con el cloruro de calcio:
cada mol en realidad tiene 2 moles de cloruro.
Entonces ya estamos pensando en el número de
moles de iones cloruro: lo que sea que tengamos en
las opciones C y D en términos del número de moles
de estas moléculas, lo tendremos que multiplicar
por 2 para obtener los moles de iones cloruro.
Si lo que acabo de decir te da una idea y no
obtuviste una respuesta la primera vez, pausa
el video nuevamente y trata de resolverlo. Muy
bien, ahora trabajemos juntos en esto. Entonces,
en esta primera opción A, la cantidad de moles
de iones cloruro es igual a, y voy a convertir
20 mililitros a litros, eso es igual a 0.020
litros de solución por 0.20, y en lugar de sólo
escribir molar voy a escribir moles de cloruro de
litio por litro, y estos son litros de solución.
Podría escribir litros de solución aquí y litros
de solución aquí; los litros se cancelan y voy a
obtener 0.004 moles de cloruro de litio. Esa es la
primera opción, A; ahora hagamos B: 15 mililitros
es lo mismo que 0.015 litros, eso es 15 milésimas
de un litro por 0.10 moles de cloruro de sodio por
litro de solución, eso nos da como resultado
0.0015, estos se cancelan, moles de cloruro de
sodio, podría escribir eso: cloruro de sodio. En
este caso es moles de cloruro de litio. Muy bien,
ahora veamos la siguiente opción. Aquí tenemos
10 mililitros, que es lo mismo que 10 milésimas
de litro por 0.25 molar, que es lo mismo que
moles, en este caso, de cloruro de magnesio, por
litro de solución, lo que nos da como resultado
0.0025 moles de cloruro de magnesio. Y luego,
en la opción D, tenemos 15 mililitros, que ya
sabemos que es lo mismo que 15 milésimas de litro,
multiplicado por 0.20 molar, es lo mismo que los
moles de cloruro de calcio por litro de solución,
y eso es igual a 0.003 moles de cloruro de calcio.
Hasta ahora hemos calculado los moles de las
moléculas enumeradas aquí. Este primer resultado
son moles de cloruro de litio, luego tenemos moles
de cloruro de sodio, moles de cloruro de magnesio,
en realidad hay dos iones cloruro por molécula,
y luego tenemos moles de cloruro de calcio.
Ahora, ¿cuántos moles de cloruro hay en cada
uno de estos? Bueno, en los primeros dos es 1
a 1, es decir si tienes 0.004 moles de cloruro
de litio vas a tener la misma cantidad de
moles de cloruro, lo mismo para la opción
B. Pero para las opciones C y D, como dijimos
anteriormente, multiplicaremos por 2. De modo
que para la opción C esto será igual a dos veces
más moles de cloruro o 0.005 moles de cloruro;
y en esta última opción también multiplicaremos
por 2, porque por cada mol de cloruro de calcio
tenemos 2 moles de cloruro, entonces esto es
igual a 0.006 moles del anión cloruro. Así
que cuando revisamos los moles de cloruro, vemos
que la opción D tiene más. Me gusta esta opción.